I had to calm myself down several times to make a response video
because I kept commenting back to this person and um
they kept getting taken down for bullying
so first thing I wanna point out is the sheer inappropriateness of this comment
to be left on that video shows a lack of tact
a lack of class a lack of compassion and empathy
also and this is the part that's really frustrating
it shows just how willfully um
you are misunderstanding any of my Tradwife content
there's a very big difference between a Tradwife and a prepper
being so willfully misunderstood
I made me so angry
mostly because you used the death and destruction of Western North Carolina
and my concern for it to make this comment
but beyond that if you are not sophisticated enough
to understand the nuance of a complex conversation
shut your mouth you don't have the skills to participate in this discussion
clearly my critique of trad wife content creators
has nothing to do with what's going on in Western North Carolina
but beyond that do you know that there are non trad wife preppers
do you know that you can make homesteading content
without a sprinkle of white supremacist rhetoric
would it shock you to know that I also grow vegetables and can bake bread
yeah because these topics aren't black and white
they have nuance and your capacity to understand that is your problem
people who are educated and sophisticated enough to have this conversation
understand what I'm talking about
and you should have the day that you deserve
and I kind of hope you pee your pants in public today